it's the sure sign of Spring's arrival
that is eagerly anticipated in South
Korea
more so through the pandemic when from
the first year in 2020 the cherry
blossom season coincided with the end of
the first surge of the virus the
delicate beauty of the bloom coming to
symbolize the hope of New Life
it's great to come back with friends and
even better with my baby
[Music]
coming back to see the flowers after
such a long time
blessed with a third of a million cherry
trees along Old railway lines and
streams the town of jinhay has the
longest established Blossom Festival in
South Korea
[Music]
and in this first full year of welcoming
back the crowds it's hoping for nearly 5
million visitors with warming
temperatures this Southeast corner of
South Korea traditionally sees the
cherry blossom first before it rolls
North up the peninsula in a wave of
color but it's already bloomed in Seoul
the second earliest date on record the
earliest being set just two years ago
in this District in Seoul the annual
celebration of the Forsythia Bloom has
been brought forward a week because the
flowers have bloomed early neighboring
Japan is also experiencing earlier
cherry blossom Tokyo this year equaling
the record for the first bloom and back
in the southeast of South Korea as the
city of kyungju prepares for its
Festival the blossoms are already
falling with several days to go
it seems to be blossoming earlier each
year which makes you think about the
environment
Nature's beautiful but seemingly ominous
barometer of dangerously Changing Times
Rob McBride Al Jazeera kyungju South
Korea